-Welcome back.
-Hi, thank you.
I'm all frazzled.
I was running late.
I'm very sorry.
-That's all right.
-The hotel lost
my pocket square.
-Uh-huh?
-They did.
Which is the gay equivalent
of "The dog ate my homework."
-Right.
-But you know...
Still, anyway, I wanted
to look beautiful for you.
-You look wonderful as always.
-All right, thank you,
thank you.
-And I actually want to talk
about appearance real quick,
because obviously
I participated in this video.
-Yes.
-And I want to talk about
glamming up the midterms.
And you said, like,
just shoot it on an iPhone,
it's not a big deal.
But then, obviously,
some people, like,
shot it with real cameras
and got hair and makeup done.
-Yes.
-And so now people like, Kimmel,
me, John Oliver,
we look terrible.
-Oh, I'm so sorry
that white men have a problem
for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
So sorry, Seth.
I know you've had a hard life.
I Mean, Harvard...
-Oh, my God.
-And right to
"Saturday Night Live."
-I did not go to Harvard,
and you know that.
-Whatever.
I don't know where you went.
[ Laughter ]
-How did you --
-But this is exciting,
and by the way, thank you for
having me to talk about this.
-Please.
-And thank you and all the hosts
in there for doing this video.
We just launched a new campaign
to encourage
and raise awareness --
Well, to encourage voting
and raise awareness
of the midterm elections
on November 6th.
A couple of -- thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And particularly
among millennials.
And I know millennials probably
hate being called millennials.
I'm sorry. Whatever.
But, the fact is, this is real.
Only 12% of millennials
voted in the last midterm
election in 2014.
Which means 88% did not vote.
And the truth of the matter is,
as you get older, you know,
the older demographics,
the percentages
aren't so much better.
That's the truth. And the fact
is, a lot of us don't vote.
I haven't voted in midterms.
-Yeah.
-And we don't like
to admit that.
But I'm just gonna say,
I haven't voted.
I want to acknowledge --
I mean, I have voted,
but I didn't vote
in every single election,
especially when I was younger.
And young people are now
the most influential,
largest voting bloc,
if you vote,
which means you have
the potential to be
the deciding factor in a lot
of these Congressional races.
So that's what "Glam Up
the Midterms" is all about.
-And that's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-You're actually going
to go on the road.
-Yes.
-You're going to go to --
-This is my favorite part.
There will be some viral videos
to raise awareness
and have fun.
But we are actually --
we've pinpointed
a number of districts
with hotly contested races.
And we're actually
going to go there
and we're going to help
educate people.
It's a bipartisan effort.
I mean,
Billy Eichner is not bipartisan,
but the effort is bipartisan.
[ Laughter ]
The effort is bipartisan.
We're going to go to
these districts,
let people know
when election day is,
where to vote, how to vote,
get them registered.
Give them information on who's
running, what the races are.
You know,
the midterms are complicated.
It's not like
the presidential election
where we're focused
on two candidates.
There's different races
in every state, every district.
It's a lot of information
for the average person
to comprehend.
And, we're going to do it
in a fun, exciting way.
-I am so glad you're doing this.
I want to ask,
sometimes when people
take up initiatives like this,
you will hear other people say,
actors should not
talk about politics.
What is your response to that?
-Let me tell you what
my response is, Seth.
-Great.
[ Light laughter ]
-Look. I understand people
don't like actors going on TV
and talking about politics,
but I'm doing this as a citizen.
I've been shouting at people on
"Billy on the Street" for years.
-Yeah.
-Whoo!
-Thank you.
But now I'm trying to use
my voice for something good.
And let me say something else,
it's ridiculous.
If you're going to tell actors
not to talk about politics,
that's like telling people
who aren't
a professional athlete
not to talk about
the Super Bowl.
-Yeah, that's a good point.
-You know, it's ridiculous.
And if actors can't talk
about the influential work
that politicians do,
I think politicians
should not be able to talk about
the influential work
that actors do.
Like on "Full House."
You know what I mean?
That's important.
-We need to talk more
about "Full House."
-We have to talk about
"Full House" and "Fuller House."
And God knows what comes next,
Seth.
[ Light laughter ]
And if actors can't talk
about politicians,
where do you draw the line?
-Yeah.
-What else can't we talk about?
Doctors?
Because I'll show you
13 seasons of "Grey's Anatomy"
that say otherwise, Seth.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Okay?
And by the way, thank you.
Thank you.
And "Grey's Anatomy"
is the perfect example.
Because that show started
a pivotal conversation
we're having in this country
right now about what happens
when exhausted, tired,
overworked emergency room
workers get horny.
-Yeah.
-You know, like --
-That wasn't a conversation
we were having.
-We needed that conversation.
-We needed it to start.
-And by the way, if you don't
like this, don't listen to me.
James Corden's on CBS.
You can watch that right now.
-I wouldn't --
I don't necessarily --
[ Laughter ]
-It's on, right, Seth?
-You don't have to.
-Right now!
-You're going to be gone
in a minute
if you can just stick it out.
[ Laughter ]
-This is more important.
Tonight James Corden
is on a unicycle
with Zac Efron singing songs
from "The Greatest Showman."
-Well, I'd like
to see that, too.
-It's a delight.
-[ Laughs ]